These two have a long, complicated history
and every time they meet it's always a coin
toss to see how they're going to react.
Will they fight?
Will they work together?
Keep watching to learn more about the bizarre
relationship between Spider-Man and Venom.
In 2007's Spider-Man 3, Peter Parker's bonding
with the Venom symbiote does more than change
the color of his costume and enhance his powers,
it makes him a jerk.
The symbiote boosts destructive emotions in
Peter, like anger and jealousy.
"When are you going to give a guy a break?"
"You want forgiveness?
Get religion."
Among other things, he hunts and attempts
to kill Sandman and brings Gwen Stacy to a
nightclub in a manipulative plan to make Mary
Jane jealous.
He even gets in a fight with the club's bouncers,
which ends with him accidentally hurting Mary
Jane.
It's this last act that makes Parker realize
what's happening and finally take action to
get rid of the symbiote.
In the comics, however, things worked out
a little differently.
While the symbiote made Spider-Man do things
against his will, it didn't do so by turning
him into an evil version of Peter Parker.
Rather than finding the costume on Earth like
he did in the film, Peter picked it up out
in space during the events of Secret Wars,
and shortly after he returned to New York
with his new suit, the symbiote apparently
decided that its host was a little too lazy.
Most nights, the symbiote waited until Parker
was asleep, took over his body, and went out
to find more crime to fight, all the while
controlling its human host's unconscious body
like a puppet.
One of the first clues Parker has that something
is wrong is when he constantly wakes up exhausted
even though, as far as he knows, he's been
asleep in bed for hours.
While the symbiote doesn't turn Peter Parker
into a jerk in the comics, it's clear it impacts
his mental state in other, more subtle ways.
How do we know?
Because it takes Peter, who's as much a scientist
as Bruce Banner and Tony Stark, a pretty long
time to start examining a strange, unknown,
symbiotic life form that he picked up on an
alien planet.
Despite the fact that it produces its own
webbing and can shape-shift to look like anything
from a costume to regular human clothing,
he doesn't get around to figuring out what
it actually is until things start to go very,
very badly.
After picking up the alien costume in Secret
Wars #8, Peter returns to Earth in Amazing
Spider-Man #252.
It's not until six months later that he finally
approaches the Marvel Universe's resident
super-scientific genius, the Fantastic Four's
Reed Richards, to help him figure out just
what's going on with his new costume.
For months, Spider-Man simply accepts the
fact that he's wearing a freaky magical alien
suit he doesn't know anything about.
Clearly, the costume's messing with his head.
It's easy to argue that during Secret Wars,
where all of Marvel's most prominent heroes
and villains were brought to another planet
and forced to battle each other, Spidey was
desperate enough to just accept whatever he
could find to boost his chances of survival.
Once he returns to Earth, though, maybe putting
that thing under a microscope should've been
his first priority.
In 1985's Web of Spider-Man #1, the symbiote
betrays the emotional connection developing
between it and Peter Parker by revealing a
quality that you might not expect from a murderous
alien life form: compassion.
While Peter is slipping on his classic red-and-blue
Spidey suit in his apartment, the symbiote
returns from being imprisoned in the Fantastic
Four's headquarters and attempts to bond with
him once again.
Peter tries to return to the Baxter Building
to get help from the F.F., but the symbiote
does everything it can to keep him away from
the building.
Eventually, Peter gets enough control to make
his way to a cathedral, taking advantage of
the symbiote's weakness to loud noises by
using the ringing of the church bells as a
weapon.
In the process, Peter gets knocked out, and
while it initially slithers away to escape
the bells, the symbiote returns to save Peter
from the thunderous sound.
The narration tells us that its bond with
Parker caused it to experience emotion for
the first time.
Before disappearing, we see the alien reach
out, caressing Peter's cheek.
In spite of the Venom symbiote bonding with
more than a dozen other characters since leaving
Peter Parker, there are two behaviors that
show us how fixated it is on Spider-Man.
First, there's its tendency to bond with people
in that are already in Peter's social circles.
Eddie Brock is the first and most obvious
example, since he was a rival photographer
at the Daily Bugle the first time he merged
with Venom.
"Photography, it's not just about, no offense,
uh flagpoles, whatever, it's about lighting,
composition, drama."
Other hosts include Mac Gargan, better known
as the Spidey villain the Scorpion, but he's
not the only established bad guy to hook up
with the symbiote.
In the pages of Superior Spider-Man, the comic
where Peter's identity was taken over by Doctor
Octopus, it temporarily bonded with Doc Ock's
brain in Spidey's body.
After Brock, the man to have stayed with the
symbiote for the longest amount of time was
Peter Parker's former bully and best friend,
Flash Thompson, who used it to perform covert
missions for the government under the codename
Agent Venom.
What's equally telling is how Venom manifests
visually.
The symbiote has the ability to mimic any
set of clothing, but no matter who the host
is or where they fall on the moral spectrum,
Venom continues to base its appearance on
Spider-Man's.
The eyes of its mask and the spider emblem
on its chest are clearly mirrors of Spidey's
costume, as is the fact that it continues
to sling "webs" around, something other symbiotes
just don't do.
Spider-Man and Venom don't exactly have the
best relationship, but occasionally, there's
something bad enough to force them to work
together, and it usually comes from Venom
himself.
More often than not, if Parker and Brock are
on the same team it's because one of Venom's
own spawn is up to no good, like the insane
and powerful villain Cletus Kasady, better
known as Carnage.
"When I get outta here, and I will, there's
gonna be Carnage."
Venom and Spidey famously teamed up against
the villainous symbiote along with other Marvel
heroes in the 1993 event Maximum Carnage,
a hugely popular storyline that inspired the
classic 16-bit video game of the same name.
There's a good reason why they had to team
up, too.
Physically, Carnage is more powerful than
Spider-Man and Venom combined, and even more
durable.
Among other things, the villain has survived
being beheaded as well as being dragged into
space and ripped in half.
Even worse, Kassady was already a convicted
serial killer before he got super-powers.
When his cellmate, Eddie Brock, escaped from
prison, a scrap of the symbiote was left behind,
and a terrifying new villain was born.
In that respect, Carnage can be thought of
as Venom's "son," but the symbiotes clearly
don't have the same warm, fuzzy feelings the
rest of us have towards family.
Still, the fact that Venom chose to stay on
Team Spidey when he had to choose between
siding with Peter Parker or teaming up with
his own spawn says a whole lot about his complicated
relationship with Spider-Man.
It's clear the Venom symbiote has complicated
feelings towards Peter Parker, but it's also
clear that those complex feelings are a two-way
street.
Venom's place in the Marvel Universe is always
cycling between anti-hero and full-on villain.
He can spend time as a less forgiving crimefighter,
as he did in a series of solo titles that
started in 1993 with Venom: Lethal Protector,
but cut to ten years later and 2003's Venom,
and he's right back to eating people for fun.
And yet, in spite of Venom's unpredictability
and his shifting loyalties, Spider-Man never
gets proactive about shutting him down, even
though he's the one with the great responsibility
of bringing the symbiote to Earth in the first
place.
Instead, he's far more likely to form an uneasy
alliance with him, like he did to battle Carnage,
and seems to hold out hope that the symbiote
could be redeemed.
That might be a result of his bond with the
symbiote leaving him with an emotional connection,
but there's plenty of evidence that Spidey
might be right after all.
During its time as Agent Venom, the symbiote
spent a long time bonded to one of Parker's
closest pals, Flash Thompson, who, in addition
to being Peter Parker's best friend, was once
literally the president of the Spider-Man
fan club.
"He's no Spider-Man."
"What is it with you and Spider-Man?"
"What?
He looks out for the neighborhood, has a dope
suit, and I really respect him!"
Thompson's Venom was a much more traditionally
heroic version of the character, and even
served alongside the Guardians of the Galaxy
and a covert squad of Avengers.
While he was out in space, the symbiote revealed
a previously unknown tragic past, starting
out as a relatively peaceful member of an
alien species called the Klyntar before being
driven mad after mistakenly bonding with a
genocidal maniac.
Thompson's innate sense of honor, however,
showed the symbiote a better way to live and
use its great power a little more responsibly.
Whether that will stick remains to be seen,
but for now, Venom seems to be pretty firmly
on the side of the good guys.
More or less.
"You gonna eat anybody else?"
"Most likely!"
Miles Morales is probably best known these
days as the star of 2018's animated hit Spider-Man:
Into the Spider-Verse.
In the comics, like in the film, Miles was
originally from an alternate universe to Peter
Parker, but was transported to the prime Marvel
Comics universe by a cosmic event that restructured
the multiverse.
As a result, when Miles runs into Eddie Brock
in 2018's Venom #3, it's their first meeting,
and their introduction doesn't go well.
With his symbiote being controlled by the
dark god Knull, Venom comes close to killing
Miles.
The younger Spider-Man manages to temporarily
incapacitate the symbiote, which gives Brock
takes over.
Eddie thanks Miles and tries to explain what
happened, but Miles doesn't give him the chance.
Miles understandably presses the attack against
Eddie, and Venom is forced to fight back.
While Miles has never met Eddie Brock before
that issue, he isn't a stranger to symbiotes.
Back in his home universe, his life was thrown
into disarray by that world's version of Venom
in 2013, during a story appropriately titled
"Venom War."
Venom nearly killed Miles' father, and his
mother died as a result of the conflict.
With that kind of history, it's easy to see
why Miles wouldn't be inclined to give Eddie
the benefit of the doubt once he was attacked.
Eventually, in true Marvel Team-Up fashion,
the fight led to Miles and Eddie working together
for the next few issues.
Time will tell what happens next time these
two fan-favorites cross paths.
Marvel has been putting out issues of What
If? on and off since 1977, giving readers
the chance to experience what stories would
be like if they worked out differently.
Usually, the answer is that things would be
pretty bad, but 1989's What If #4 takes things
to the next level.
The question this time around is "What if
the alien had possessed Spider-Man?" and things
wind up a whole lot worse for everyone, including
both Peter Parker and the symbiote.
The Venom symbiote of What If?
#4 never develops the same emotional attachment
to Peter Parker as the main continuity's Venom
does.
Instead, it feeds on its host like a vampire,
draining Peter's youth and vitality in the
process.
Once Parker's life force is spent, the symbiote
starts looking for a bigger meal and chooses
the Hulk as his next host.
It interrupts the massive battle between the
Hulk and the Avengers that readers had originally
seen in Incredible Hulk #300, and bonds with
the Green Goliath.
As he does, Peter Parker's body is revealed
to have been prematurely aged, leaving him
as a withered husk.
Peter dies not long after, and the Avengers
pursue the Venom-infected Hulk until the symbiote
trades up once again, leaving the Hulk's body
for Thor's.
The heroes finally incapacitate Venom by getting
help from the Inhuman leader Black Bolt, whose
deafening scream forces the symbiote from
Thor's body, and destroys Mount Rushmore in
the process.
Before the assembled heroes can banish the
symbiote to another dimension, the Black Cat
kills it in revenge for Parker's death.
All things considered, it's a much less happy
ending than we got in the regular comics.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.